oh did you fart oh my god go down again
let's go breasts - Peter Pan welcome to
quantum break I'm very excited for this
game it was made by remedy entertainment
which is the studio that made Alan Wake
and I hope it's a good game it looks
really really cool you might have seen
the trailer of it already it was
announced that he's e3 it was a big
title for Xbox and the thing is you can
squeeze time I don't know when I saw the
trailer I'm like that looks [ __ ] dope
I can't wait to play that game without
further ado let's start a new series if
you wouldn't be so kind
leave a like show some support it really
helps out with series and I really
appreciate it so and a lot of you bros
really enjoy doing new gameplay also if
you at any point feel like this is a
cool game I want to check it out you can
pause just pause check out the link in
description and get the game I don't
know anything that's too bad to happen
except freezing time act 1 the number
one killer is time number one killer is
time that is true we all die destroys us
all ok that [ __ ] cools what you need
to know ok
time broke a growing fracture leading to
the end of time my time can't break we
went after a device that could fix it
thanks turd ugly pulse we was there to
stop us
he has superpowers yeah and with me both
oh my god is badass
we failed yeah I know that actress
time-travels Jack going too fast for you
yes okay what do you want to cover first
I don't know let's start at the
beginning when you first arrived at
river port University monarch solution
that is a big-ass [ __ ] Tower look at
that [ __ ] back home to see my best
friend Paul serene a good old player I
show me what he'd been working on my
brother will was a scientist he was also
involved Paul said it was world-changing
that's right you're going man haha she
clearly walk get out of that rose chic
really walked out of the road without
paying attention alright river port
University here we are
hey thanks for the ride I thought he's
gonna brofist Sam that's why I Drive off
- hey did we get to play come on let me
play yeah oh my god in a way for six
years Paul and I had kept in touch but
well not so much how did it make you
feel I was just happy to see Paul hey
how you doing baby how you doing what
have you want I don't have the time yeah
the time yes let's go oh that's a pole
my biggest enemy you made a long trip
just to see a research project well
reading between the lines Paul was under
a lot of pressure I needed a friend I
wanted to help him any way I could son
of a [ __ ] Jack Joyce
in the flesh the esteemed mr. Paul
serene shaken moneybags Shutts shaking
moneybags well c'mon yeah yet six years
now we're starting you never come back
yeah me too
come on what is this all about
this way we're going upstairs to the
project lab how was the flight it was
great
first class thank you for that to step
up from our van trip to Utah I'm
guessing the Wills not meeting us I'm so
excited we're here I knew Paul had asked
my brother will to consult on his
project will was all the family I had
but he was difficult
can you walk any slower come on let's
just get to the big show yeah let's get
to the big show what is this all about
Paul you haven't changed at all that's
right I just want the superpowers give
me the superpowers Paul I know what
you're on to project prominent prominent
lamest name I ever heard so are your
jeans they look like something my dad
would wear loser that I just called my
dad and loser I mean those are the
coolest pants swagalicious you can't
goddamnit
okay here we are holy [ __ ]
you guys must have some budget what is
all this yeah what is that you jury Jack
you were looking at the biggest
discovery about what time of our time
pressive but wills the scientist what do
you need me for
there's a reason we're doing this at
4:00 a.m. Jack I need someone I can
trust I need you to help me convince
will yeah I had a hunch when your
brother found out the scope of what we
were building here he well he puts it
out you know will ya hang on I gotta get
something for my desk well that's a nice
goat it scared off the investors ranting
about miscalculations dangers all with
no evidence it works but they're gonna
cut our funding if I don't prove it I
see the concept of personal space is
still far into you hey somebody's got to
keep tabs on you they're just hat
jockeys email nice nice going brother
Jack you know asking for our help is not
easy for me I am in deep trouble you see
the tests I have to run here are not
strictly speaking legal you're the only
one I can trust to help me with this
okay fine did I want to make it right a
man I love my older brother but he
didn't make it easy it's already
essentially setup anyone can do it but
you're the one I want to do this with
Jack thank you I knew I could count on
you
hey brother no problem brother don't
mention it brother hey what do we got he
like I'm gonna read that for reals
what's that I need you to push the lever
over there labeled cronin conduit
that'll activate the core
I'm gonna run Diagnostics and make sure
it remains stable yeah now that seems
like a great idea
I'll activate the lever it's called
lever [ __ ] idiot press forward good
it's a heavy lever did I do it right
just the Krone on conduit initiating of
course of course silly of me are you
sure it's supposed to do that
was a the core replicates the effects of
a rotating micro black hole so
activating it can be a bit intense
thanks for the headsup black hole what
exactly are we testing here you're about
to find out that looks [ __ ] awesome
to raise the corridor this is so
exciting times a slightly illegal
moderately reckless that's building a
time machines I could tell this was
different still I didn't understand how
massive and far-reaching the
consequences for this would be how could
I
I knew Paul on this is awkward let's do
this press we need to turn the keys at
the same time to activate security
precautions ready it's like we're
launching a nuke sorry to wait we're not
launching a new way to find out
three-two-one I pressed a little early
just to see what happens
did I [ __ ] it up what is the corridor
the passenger enters one end traveled
around the loop exits the other
at the predetermined time in the
physical location with me you're
actually going inside that thing in the
machine to time
well what that [ __ ] I'm going to be the
first Jack and you're my witness
this is crazy all and this can't be safe
what happens when our team has already
proved it works in the trial phase it is
ready we've passed every test every
inspection we're about to make history
jack however I have to do all right hit
that switch all right got it two minutes
to the pass
boom
boom two minutes to the past remember
this moment
now I'll forget about it we already did
it that's cool that's awesome now they
can make out finally I ship them so much
oh my god Samir's it are haha it's okay
stay calm
Jack stay calm there's there's two of
you you just [ __ ] multiplied
this is exactly what was supposed to
happen that's he's he's me a future
version of me from two minutes in the
future your evil future self i ship i
did it they're gonna kiss [ __ ]
incredible why me just imagine the
implications we could warn people about
disasters before they happen or they
happen sure is easy because spread oh
god this is already getting annoying
still sounds good second time Jesus
Christ now go into the machine you need
to complete the cycle yeah yes of course
wait Paul when medically it's all a big
loop Jackie I need to enter the Machine
and travel back to the moment I exited
the machine in order to well
be here and what if you don't yeah
there is no what if I'm here it's
already happened boy you saw it Jack we
did it but that's impossible that's
that's literally impossible I mean I
can't even there's no time to stop now
we need to test the other direction set
the machine to five minutes to the
future five minutes to the future I'm
glad you trust me to do this
this guy that doesn't know jack [ __ ]
oops I put it to five minutes
Oh God that says what are you doing oh
my god it's him it's Frodo's friend to
this we have to shut this thing down now
the car along we can't shut it down
Paul's still in there oh honey look at
me put the gun down and we can talk okay
then do anything bad Frodo straight put
the gun down
Jesus Christ well time is going to end
Jack you have to trust me or what
no I gotta let job
[ __ ] oh man man how can time end
what does that mean
okay I think so I'll find way out make
sure was okay yeah yeah good job Rick oh
that oh okay that looks fine ah this
looks mine wills words in my head hey
he's going to end you were there when
time broke where were you when this
happened god damn I hate when that
happens I hate when I break time because
that's I'm pushing the objects look at
that that's awesome look at the iPad
just floating around oh [ __ ] there he is
this is crazy but here's my number so
call me later
well he's stuck in time uh hahaha he has
to touch Hey
what have we done I don't know Frodo she
wanted me I knew she was right all this
time I want Paul this could all been
avoided we're too late
this is so cool by the way I've never
seen anything like it
some dope [ __ ] I'm so glad I'm playing
it No
am I going to fight the baddies now
the machine oh wait so Jack
what are we doing escape the lab I can't
even escape anything what the hell am i
oh the Hat oh okay I didn't want to be
Paul but there was no way to help I
didn't know where he'd end up dumb [ __ ]
I have way better pants every day why is
he looking at me oh the hell sorry
which way I already left me your schmuck
Oh that'll move yeah yeah you like that
oh it looks so real your hands look so
smooth I want to kiss them wait nothing
I don't say anything I'm gonna touch the
rule making body whoa what I can stop
time dodged the bullet like matrix staff
Oh Dan that's badass yeah that's right
whoa check you just I am the chosen one
what just go this way move day three I
was the first time my power started to
manifest an out-of-control burst of
energy that saved well
hey nice spread buddy what the hell is
happening that's what I'm telling you
not in the right language huh yeah
what's going on man why did I pick up a
gun come on make time go bad oh thanks
time is an egg then that egg is [ __ ]
broken the time egg is [ __ ]
what oh why is there a goodness oh my
god
Jesus Christ it's a fracturing time it's
breaking down leading to the end of time
and door what locked they cut my
security clearance I don't see why they
could have done that that didn't help
ha ha ha I'll get it on why do I am what
am I so confident I could do it all
right well [ __ ] me I'll do it I'll press
some buttons I I pressed buttons before
hey the good old punishment more than
hide but we have a gun now yeah they're
coming yeah nah okay fine
I want Paul about this about the
calculations I tried to make it listen
to me by shoving a gun in my face yes a
gun mm-hmm the universal symbol for shut
the [ __ ] up and listen to me sound logic
about you you're on this side
we sure he didn't head back up the lab
comeback service elevator out of it this
doesn't make any sense
how orders are turkey why are you even
here your biggest concern right now plus
you're not Paul brought me here to clean
up your mess
my mess do you even know nice one good
job
let's go
well they just lucked out Jesus Christ
yet you have no context for any of this
Jack you weren't here
lot happens in six years it's bigger
than us can't make it personal I'm
trying to kill us will it's pretty
goddamn person yeah what are they trying
to murder us listen getting you involved
is the last thing I wanted I'm sorry
right hey these things happen
now wait thanks thanks a lot man look at
your skin next well just me all right
we'll find god damn it
you have to get to my car okay you're
better at the door thing the door thing
that's my that's my thing here we go one
two three Dorothy Hey opening fire oh
it's your chair
tip don't you dare shoot chair nailed it
holy [ __ ] how did you survive that there
it is holy [ __ ] that's awesome oh [ __ ]
not again not again what are you doing
inside me dude this is really awkward
holy [ __ ] looks [ __ ] awesome holy
[ __ ] look at that I'm [ __ ] spraying
the [ __ ] out of them oh my god what is
that a shock wave that I did holy [ __ ]
all right well so [ __ ] cool this game
leave it like please do I really
appreciate it if you want more and let
me know in the comments I would love to
do more coverage of this game I think it
looks really cool
and I would love to have you bros along
with me while we go on this adventure
together
so yeah let's do that I'll see you
brothers in the next part thank you so
much for watching and as always stay
mother [ __ ] me y'all know me
same old [ __ ] surely we must go down
here